let's solve some more rational equations
so let's say i have
x
plus
1 over x
is equal to
2. once again we have an x and a
denominator over here it looks kind of
bizarre but you just have to remember if
we multiply every term in this equation
by this denominator right here by this
by this x
right there then it'll essentially the
you'll have x times one over x and this
it'll just the x will disappear out of
the denominator so let's do that so we
have to multiply every term by that you
can't just multiply one term so multiply
this term times x
this term times x and then the 2 times x
we're just multiplying both sides of
this equation by this denominator so
what do we get
we get x times x is x squared plus
x times one over x is just one x's
cancel out
and then that's going to be equal to 2x
that's going to be equal to 2x
and this is starting to look like our
standard quadratic equations we just
have to subtract 2x from both sides and
if we do that so let me subtract
2x from there subtract 2x from there
the left-hand side of our equation
becomes x squared
minus 2x
plus 1. and the right-hand side is equal
to zero
and we know how to solve an equation
like this we could either factor or use
the quadratic formula but this actually
seems pretty straightforward to factor
negative one times negative one is one
negative one plus negative one is
negative two so this is
x
minus one
times x minus one is equal to zero and
we know if two numbers when you multiply
them they equal zero that means one or
both of those numbers have to be equal
to zero in this situation the number is
the same right this is x minus one
squared is equal to zero right so we
know that x minus one has to be equal to
zero add one to both sides of this
equation
and we get x
is equal to
1.
and you can verify it verify that this
works
verify that this works 1 plus 1 over one
does indeed equal two so it definitely
does work let's do a more involved one
now now that we're
now that we're warmed up
let's say i have
two
over
2 over
x squared
plus 4 x plus 3
is equal to
plus
2 plus x minus 2 over
x minus 3.
so just like we've done in the last
problem and all the other ones we want
to get all of these x's out of the
denominator and the best way to do it is
to multiply every term in this equation
by you can view it as the least common
multiple of the denominator so let me
show you what i'm talking about the
first thing we might want to do is
factor this to see if this guy and this
guy have anything in common
so let's see if we can factor it what
two numbers when you multiply them equal
three and then you add them equal four
well three and one right so this
this right here i can rewrite it as x
x plus three
and
x plus
three and oh and really this is a plus
over there too i wrote the original
problem wrong
that is a product so the this this over
here on the left is x plus three times x
plus 1.
and so what can we multiply both sides
of this equation by to get rid of the x
plus 3 and an x plus 1 here and an x
plus 3 over there
well we multiply everything by
x plus 3
and then by x plus 1. so this
this expression right here is actually
divisible by this so the least common
multiple of x plus 3 and x squared plus
4x plus 3 is actually x squared plus 4x
plus 3 because this is a multiple of
that it's divisible by it so let's
multiply both sides of the equation by
this expression right here so we're
going to get we're going to get let me
just rewrite it x plus 3
times x plus 1 and then we have this
term over here times
two
over
x plus three times x plus one
is going to be equal to
times this two
times that two over there
plus
x plus 3 times x plus 1 times this term
times x minus 2 over
x plus 3.
now the whole reason why we did that is
because that will cancel with that the
left-hand side of our equation will just
be a 2
and 2 will be equal to
well 2 times this
2 times this we know what this is equal
to x plus 3 times x plus one is
x squared plus four x plus three we know
that we actually went the other way we
factored it so it's going to be two
times x squared plus four x plus three
which is two times x squared is let me
do it in that green color so you know
we're dealing with this 2 right here so
this term right here is going to be 2
times x squared so it's 2
x squared plus 2 times 4x
plus
8x plus 2 times three
six
and now this term we have an x plus
three in the numerator or it would be if
i multiplied it times this fraction or
this rational expression that x plus
three will cancel with that x plus three
so we're just left with an x plus one
times an x minus two
and x plus one times x minus two let me
just focus in on this expression right
here x plus one i'll just box the whole
thing
x plus 1
x plus 1 times x minus 2 is let's just
say it's x times x which is x squared
x times negative 2 which is negative 2 x
and then you have one times x so plus x
and then you have one times negative two
so you have minus two
and now we can simplify it so once again
the left hand side of this equation is
still two
now on the right hand side let's look at
the x squared terms we have a 2x squared
and we have an x squared add them
together you get 3 x squared
then
we have we have an 8x and we have a
minus 2x plus x so what's that going to
be this is an 8x and then when you add
these together you just get a minus you
just get a negative x so when you add
everything together you're going to get
a plus
seven
x
plus seven x those are the x terms and
then finally you have a so i already use
the orange
you have a six
and you have a
minus two so that's going to be plus
and now let's subtract 2 from both sides
of this equation let's subtract 2 from
both sides and we are left with
0 is equal to three x squared plus seven
x we're subtracting two from both sides
so four minus two is plus
two so we're we've stumbled we've turned
this bizarre looking thing into kind of
a standard plain vanilla quadratic
equation but we have a non-zero
coefficient out here we might well we
just want to solve for we actually don't
even have to factor it so we might as
well just use the quadratic formula
that's the easiest way to solve
especially especially a quadratic
equation that has a nine a non-one
coefficient on the x squared term so our
solutions using the quadratic formula x
is going to be equal to negative b which
is negative seven plus or minus
the square root of b squared that's 7
squared which is 49
minus 4 times a which is 3
times c which is 2
all of that
all of that over 2 times a over 2 times
3 is 6.
so what does this equal to 4 times 3
is 12 times 2 is 24. so that right there
is 24.
what's 49 minus 24 what's 25
25 so i want i want to make that too
messy so let me rewrite it so x
is equal to negative 7 plus or minus
the square
plus or minus the square root of
49 minus 24 is 25
over
6 which is equal to negative 7 plus or
minus 5 the square root of 25
over 6 and let's see if we were to add 5
that'd be negative 7 plus 5 is negative
2 over 6 which is equal to negative 1 3
that is one solution
and then if i do negative seven
minus five
that is negative twelve over six which
is equal to negative two so those are
our two solutions
to this original original rational
equation this original rational equation
right up here hopefully you enjoyed that